the base B of T of a triangle is
decreasing at a rate of 13 meters per
hour and the height H of T of the
triangle is increasing at a rate of 6
meters per hour at a certain instant T
Sub Zero the base is 5 meters and the
height is 1 meter what is the rate of
change of the area a of T so our area is
going to be a function of T what is the
rate of change of the area of the
triangle at that instant and so what
we're doing this exercise instead of
going straight and trying to solve it
what we need to do here is to identify
the various units of different
expressions and then try to think about
what information is given and what's not
and then that will actually equip us to
actually solve this rate of change
problem so let's just do this first part
let's match each expression with its
units and like always pause the video
and see if you can do it on your own
alright so the first one is B prime of T
so this is the rate of change at which
of which the base is changing with
respect to time so if we think about it
B of T that is the base that is going to
be in meters so this is going to be in
meters if we say B prime of T this is
going to be how much our base is
changing with respect to time so this is
going to be meters per and they give us
right over here they say it's decreasing
at a rate of 13 meters per hour so the
unit's here are meters per hour and so B
prime of T that is going to be in meters
per hour a at time T sub 0 remember a is
the area of our triangle and we're
measuring everything in meters you can
tell from the information they've given
us and so area is going to be in square
units and so it's going to be in square
meters now the height at time T sub 0
well both the base and the height
those are lengths they're going to be
measured in meters and so our height
time T Sub Zero is going to be in meters
and then here we have the rate of change
of our area with respect to time so our
area we already know is in meter squared
but we want to know this here the this
is going to be the rate of change of our
area with respect to time so it's going
to be an amount of area per unit time
and time here we're using hours as you
can see from some of the information
they've given us so this is going to be
area per unit time or meter squared per
hour so it's going to be right over here
that's area per unit time and the length
we're using in this is meters and time
is hours all right
now they say match each expression with
its given value so what is the base of
the triangle at time T sub zero do they
give that to us well let's see
they say at a certain time at a certain
instant T Sub Zero the base I'm gonna
underline this in a different color the
base at a certain instant T Sub Zero
the base is five meters so they say the
base at time T Sub Zero the base is a
function of time but they tell us that
it is five meters so this is five meters
right over here now what about the rate
of change of the base with respect to
time do they tell us that well look
right over here yeah that's actually the
first piece of information they gave us
the base B of T of a triangle is
decreasing at a rate of 13 meters per
hour so the rate of change of the base
that is B prime of T which is equal to
DB DT and they tell us that that is it's
decreasing at a rate of 13 meters per
hour so that would be negative 13 meters
per hour and so the rate of change of
the base with respect to time is going
to be negative 13 they gave us that now
a prime of T this is the rate of change
of the area at time T sub zero did they
give us this well they asked us that
what is the rate of change of the area
ace a of T of the triangle at that
instant so this is what we actually need
to figure out but they haven't given it
to us otherwise there's no problem to
solve so this one right over here is not
given in fact this is what we are trying
to solve for and then finally we have
the chain the first derivative of the
height with respect to time so you could
view this as d H DT what is this going
to be do they give it to us well look
right over here they say the height of
the triangle is increasing at a rate of
6 meters per hour so if they're saying H
of T is increasing they're telling us
the rate of change of H of T with
respect to time so that's H prime of T
and they're telling us that it is
increasing at 6 meters per hour so it's
going to be positive 6 meters per hour
so they did indeed give us that now why
is all of this a useful exercise to go
through well now we are really ready to
solve the question because in general if
we're talking about any triangle we know
that area is equal to 1/2 base times
height now in this situation area and
our base and our height they're all
going to be functions of T so we could
write a of T is equal to 1/2 times B of
T times H of T and if we want to find
the rate of change of our area at that
instant and the instant that they're
talking about is at time T sub 0 well
then what we would want to do is take
the derivative of both sides with
respect to T so the derivative on the
left hand side with respect to T would
be a prime of T and then on the right
hand side it would be 1 half times and
we would actually use a combination of
well it's really just the product rule
right over here the derivative of the
first function with respect to T so it's
B prime of T times the second function
this is just the product rule here plus
the first function B of T times the
derivative of the second function with
respect to time
and we need to figure out not just the
general expression they want us to know
what the rate of change of the area so a
prime of T at that instant at T Sub Zero
so what we want to figure out we want to
figure out a prime of at time T Sub Zero
well that's just going to be equal to
one half times B prime of T Sub Zero
times H of T Sub Zero plus B of T Sub
Zero times H prime of T Sub Zero now
that this might seem daunting except
they've given us a lot of this
information what is B prime of T Sub
Zero well they tell us the rate of
change of B with respect to time and it
seems like it's going just gonna stay at
negative 13 meters per hour so they gave
us this H what is the height at time T
Sub Zero well they tell us right over
here at a certain instant the base is 5
meters and the height is 1 meter so they
give us both B and H at T Sub Zero so
they gave us this they gave us this and
what is the rate of change of the height
at time T Sub Zero well they tell us the
height of the triangle is increasing at
a rate of 6 meters per hour so they tell
us that as well all of that stuff is
given and so you just have to plug it in
to figure out what is the rate of change
of the area at T sub zero at that
instant